Gang Gang
yeah
[Music]
celebrate
we celebrate man
oh yeah oh yeah
know it let's have some fun while we all
die
that's it celebrate dark days celebrate
living let's have some fun
let's have some fun thank you guys for
for turning me on it is Thursday
February 22nd that deuce deuce that
Double Deuce that Double Deuce I'm
feeling anxious I got that Anxi I got
that Anxi in me you know and that anxa
gets in me and my arms I can almost some
of them I feel like I can feel the hair
growing in my arms I can almost feel the
hair kind of growing in my arms like a
cat like a cat that's just licking on a
you know licking on a on an electrical
wire and not sucking on its ears zapping
but just getting that you know and I
feel my arms feeling a little electric I
think I've had too much coffee today and
that's some time that happened when I've
had you know when you don't drink or do
dope you start looking for that next hit
and that could be anything sometimes I
found myself do one time I made a coffee
put like probably 19 creamers in it you
know the little creamers what is that
that's some type of addiction you know
next II know I'm creamed up and I see no
I'm dripping I could kind of just
dripping at the corners of my mouth with
that soft white dairy drop just flying
out of off of daddy's little you know
flying off a daddy's little you know
face creases just dripping out like that
drool baby just like that invalid sauce
just sliding out the side of my mouth
just I mean that coffee was so creamy I
couldn't even swallow it I remember I'd
put it in my mouth and it would just
kind of just just find its way out and
that was too creamy and some of
sometimes you can't get that creamy but
yeah I just feel anxious my heart is
rattling a little I feel kg I feel kg
ever get like that feeling kg and I feel
like that a lot of times um one thing
about you know being sober and not doing
drugs and alcohol is that I get a stamp
hate you man and you know I feel this I
feel this little fire in the back of my
neck and I don't know what it is it's
just uh it's like the devil just lit a
match a long time ago before maybe even
before I was born the devil just little
match and just set it at the inside the
base of my brain at the very very bottom
like say if your brain had like a
landscape okay and out there somewhere
at the beginning of the landscaper in
the middle of the landscape there was a
wishing well and you'd look down in that
wishing well and it's just dark in there
and at the very bottom of that wishing
well that's where the devil put a little
just a little flame and that little
flame is just in me and it's always it's
in me and when I start you know just you
know turning it into that dark night and
when I start dark art and and start
being wild buying liquor or cocaine any
of that then that's when I can feel that
thing getting you know heating up
heating up inside of me and it's uh and
it just you know and if I don't do if I
don't do drugs and alcohol that flame is
still there and it still wants to latch
onto other things so it'll still find
ways to to ignite and sometimes those
ways are you know putting 19 coffees in
a creamer sometimes those ways are you
know I remember one time I was at the
CVS and some kid some little kid was
being an [ __ ] and he was wearing
striped shirts he had on striped shirts
and striped pants and right out of that
is that's the most [ __ ] [ __ ] thing
you can do is wear double stripes and
not be an inmate or be a you know a
Hamburglar or you know or not being a
man of constant sorrow and wear double
stripes and they have one of those
little inflatable basketballs or
something that that you know is for sale
and in one of those little bins or kits
and I just I took that thing out of that
little band that inflatable ball and
just hummed it at this kid
and it and it hit him strong where that
shoulder meets the neck that soft little
shelf you know it's like just that soft
little shelf it just seems like a lot
like a it's that soft place like just
like a lion lick tear right there while
you were being formed like you were
being formed out of clay and then they
were trying to make the perfect shape
for that around you where your neck
meets your shoulder and a big lion comes
and just licks that clay and that's
where they that's where that ball hit
him real hard right in that lion lick
and I don't know if I taught him a
lesson but I I know I taught him
something that boy and I don't know who
he was and that was actually I was at an
a MP and they don't have a MP anymore a
MP was a it was a chain grocery that
they used to have and they had him by me
and and we go over there me and one of
my buddies and this was a young urban
gentleman who was a good friend of mine
named Evan and we'd go over there and
buy plums and peaches when I was when I
was young but but armor one time acting
out that way just letting that flame
that was inside of me you know it's that
flame that says oh go do that do that
that's bad do that do that do something
you know that thing inside you that
makes you want to growl that makes you
want to just you know sharpen you just
sharpen your nails and just uh and just
touch and just you know touch somebody
real hard and aggressively and that's
what that is and so I think sometimes
that's just been you know I don't know
when I get to feeling anxious I feel
like that that thing inside of me you
know the little coffin inside of me that
where the devil sleeps is starting to is
starting to open up a little and you can
see the devil's eyes kind of just come
up in that space between the lid of the
coffin and the rest of the coffin you
can see his eyes come up and look out
into the world and see what trouble he
can call us and I think I'm just feeding
I'm just feeling that inside of myself
right now and I don't know what that is
you know I don't know what that is I
don't think that I'm broken I just think
that
you know that's my dark art and and
that's going on inside of me what's up
with you guys happy day to you I hope
your day is good you know I hope it's I
hope it's something that you you know I
want you to be inspired somebody hit me
with that text message the other day
they said out of the blue in the morning
at 7:30 it was today actually it was the
guy at work at the car dealership this
man big Steven green and he fell down in
his bathroom a couple of weeks ago and
and bruised his ribs real badly on a
bamboo trashcan but he this morning you
know he text me and he just said be
inspired that's what he said and I was
like wow that's getting you know that
made my you know that made my nuts kind
of square up a little you know and I've
always wished that I could have square
nuts you could stack your nuts on top of
each other when you went when when uh
when you meant business that's one thing
I like about these round nuts they just
there's too much room for comfort for
relaxation as a man I've always felt
like I needed square nuts that if when
it's time to party when it's time to go
hard you know when it's time to when
it's time to be active in time to you
know just when it's time to testify when
it's time to take action you could stack
your nuts one on top of the other and
say Gang Gang let's go to work that's
why I'm at and that's where I'm at today
we got that hamster ranch video up its
up for patreon right now and it'll go
through the patreon system and it will
come out and just be on YouTube in in a
few days but that's out there and that's
done and I want to thank everybody for
for being a part of that you know and
for letting us see them hamsters man
I've had my dreams have been filled with
furry little feet and I've gotten so
many questions and enquiries about it
and I just you know to see 6,000 of
those you know beautiful little floor
bears all at one time it just
strengthens your heart and it lets you
know the power of Mother Nature let you
know the power of Mother Nature I
some coffee right here today and this is
a single origin
yeargh aha feeb Lindh and I don't know
if this [ __ ] is made out of you know I
don't know how many blood diamonds are
in the bottom of this stuff but it's
strong you know this stuff will make you
I mean it'll make you scalp your cousin
it'll make you scalp your cousin so I uh
you know I was in Portland a couple
weeks ago and I didn't tell you guys
that I met a fellow there who didn't
have a he didn't have us you know
everybody have two front teeth most
people most people have two front teeth
unless they're doing crack cocaine or
methamphetamine czar unless they're dead
this boy had one front tooth and the
rest of his teeth were all beautiful
well manicured you know shiny pieces
elements strong elements and and he had
he was missing one and is he was sitting
there with his parents and I said Wow I
said you know you out a piece bruh and
his mom goes you know he lost it when he
was about six years old and he didn't
want a replacement and he's like yeah
you know I didn't want it and people
made fun of me for a while he goes but
now it's one of the coolest it's a he
goes I feel like it's one of the neatest
or coolest things about me and I had to
agree I was like damn this guy you know
running one light in the grill you know
this guy playing chess but he missing a
rook and it was it was kind of
empowering you know it's kind of
empowering to embrace to see somebody
you know just brave to be kind of that
different and I don't know if I have
that ability sometimes to brave to be
that different you know I think a lot
about a Justin you know or wishing I was
differently shaped you know and um you
know I go on and off of fit so where I
wear my neck brace at night because I'm
trying to you know I've always thought
my necklace too short and I've talked
about that you know I've complained I
got medium length arms and you don't
notice it until you you know you you got
an opportunity to hug someone or
something you can't do it as
well as you wish you could or when you
you know you're playing hoops and all of
a sudden your arms
they just feel they don't feel as you
can get something you can't reach for
that ball or you know you go to shoot
the ball and the ball doesn't even
really go up above your head it just
kind of goes in front of your face
because your arms aren't that long and
just you know I've always I don't know I
don't know if I've always embraced the
differences about myself as much as I
wish I had and I wonder what differences
we'll have in the future you know in the
future like people are already getting
you know big holes in their ears or
people are getting implemented like
studs put into their face you know in
the future I mean I think we're only
probably 10 or 15 years away from people
having dorsal fins you know you might
have a cousin show up with a couple
tentacles coming out of his back I mean
it's the beach is gonna be a whole
different ballgame you know when we can
do just all kinds of different things
when you could you know do some arugam
and shape your ears fold them into
little swans or you know little bitty
picture you know maybe a little shape
your ears and you know meet your
favorite boxer or something your
favorite prizefighter you might have
Muhammad Ali ears or Sugar Ray Leonard
lobes you know it's just you know it's
amazing to think you know that you know
what things are gonna be available in
the future you know if they're gonna be
able to make a horn and put it in your
skull where it come I don't think we're
far away I don't think we're far away
man and when I think about how fast that
future is coming I mean it's just
lightning fast it's lightning fast the
things that are happening the changes
that are going on and it's man it's just
a wild world it's a wild world that's
what I've been feeling but yeah I'm just
I don't know just feeling anxious today
you know I appreciate it though a lot of
you guys made calls into the hotline we
were talking about that war of the
States and what that would be like and
something's gonna wrap that up a little
bit this week I'm you know I'm gonna get
into some of you guys's calls and stuff
like that and
yeah what else I you know I'm
considering it you know getting us an
actual studio and I'm going to look at
some tomorrow so I'm pretty hopeful you
know it's an expense but sometimes I'm
realizing that you know sometimes the
things in life it's like you want
something you have to you know it's easy
to take the easy steps but then
sometimes there's that space where
you're like oh man there's not a step
right here what do I do you know there's
nothing I don't see that stare and
you'll tell you'll have people that have
been higher to different levels or
further you know further out into their
fear a sphere you know further out into
their fears further out into their fear
of fear
and and you and you'll hear them you'll
be like they'll be like look I promise
you there's there's a step there but you
don't know it and you got to move that
leg out there and you have to you know
know that something is going to be under
you or know that something is going to
show up or know that at the very least
if it doesn't you know if something
sturdy doesn't surmount under your foot
or under the weight of your attempt that
you can you can always go back to where
you are and I guess you know I mean I
just think about that like I don't know
it's just you know get a studio and then
you know be able to have guests in you
know cuz right now tape out at a house
you notice Studios built this just my
dining room is built out but you know if
you invite guests over you want to have
guests on the on the cast you invite
them over you just like do you want to
be you know in your dining room you know
is that nerve racking if somebody comes
over you know I already get nervous some
people come over to my house you know it
already makes me nervous so I don't know
so it's just you know it's just that but
then that risk of Oh am I gonna look
stupid am I gonna be you know how am I
gonna be able to I gonna feel
uncomfortable sometimes the guests and
stuff like that
I don't know I guess if I do I just can
say it but yeah I don't know that I
guess so someone maybe what's going on
inside of me some of this energy is uh
is some fear you know some anxiety so I
don't mean to drop that on you guys you
know I know this is a funny podcast or
it's supposed to be funny but man I
don't know sometimes we're like to me
there's no separation between we're
funny starts and where reality goes
there's nothing I mean there's nothing
nothing right there you know it was like
sometimes just not very much space
between the two I had a good time in La
Jolla I was in La Jolla last weekend and
we sold out the shows and I want to
thank everybody that came out where my
boy Jeremy Scipio and young ass on to
Comedy Store comedians they came down
with me
Jeremy Scipio really funny I mean both
guys super funny you know two of the
funniest guys that I've worked with the
you know as openers and we're just all
so so different you know a song from mom
he's from you know his family is is a
Indian I believe or maybe Middle Eastern
and I'm sure I sounds stupid not knowing
which one but oh well at least I took a
shot at two of them you know I know he's
not Norwegian so there you go bang bang
and then Jeremy Scipio you know and he's
uh you know kind of a darker skin got
urban you might say urban but it was
great man we had a good time happy Black
History Month if you celebratin you know
and and I was thinking about like
usually Black History Month is a thing
that's you know super celebrated and
this year I felt I don't know I felt
kind of nervous to mention it I don't
know if that resonates with anybody out
there but I felt nervous too
I don't know I feel like you like like
if I don't know sometimes I feel this
weird thing as a white guy that like if
you mentioned stuff or try to be excited
about stuff that is you know black
centric or African American that
people judge you for doing that you know
or you'll get you know flak like oh you
know you're not black why you celebrate
this has nothing to do with you you know
I feel like there's I don't know
sometimes it's hard for us all to move
forward when you feel like you can't
even be happy for another culture or
race or ethnicity without getting you
know accused of being like kind of
pompous about it if that makes any sense
you know like Oh what do you you know
black it you know you're not black like
it should have anything to do with you
you know oh you're feeling guilty so
you're saying this sort of thing you
know I feel like I said that I don't
know that's one of the toughest things
that sometimes you know is to feel I
don't know this this year I felt it I
felt like oh it's by kiss your month but
you know I feel like if if I say
anything then people call you like a you
know like you're just trying to you know
fake support or you're just trying to
you know make yourself feel okay about
you know you know white guilt or I don't
know all kinds of I don't know I don't
know just sharing [ __ ] that's in my head
so I don't know it's a lot of anxiety I
guess this week you know and it happens
sometimes sometimes I get that anxiety I
mean it's just a weird time they get the
floor to school shooting people and you
know a lot of stuff in the news about
that and I'm gonna say this man if we
can't if we can't keep guns out of
schools then let's say I say no school
no more school and I know that might be
a crazy reach but no more school you
know if people are playing shoot him up
at school houses than no more you know
and I think about when this stuff
started because when I was at when I was
young when I was in school this stuff it
was that was not a concern our biggest
concerns I remember in the office at
school they had a UH they had alarm
thing and they had
regular bail then they had a button next
to it and it said tornado and then a
button next to it said nuclear and those
were our biggest three fears and if
there was like a fight sometimes on a
playground people would you know tangle
a couple people would tangle up but that
was that was it I mean if I go back in
my mind and you know I'm sorry if I'm
talking about some of this stuff and
it's a downer and you know you didn't
want this as part of your morning and
and that sort of thing and you know I
don't get on here a lot of times of the
plane as to what I'm gonna talk about
but if you don't want that sort of thing
you know when I was young that wasn't I
could not even have imagined that and
I'm sure most kids now can't imagine it
until it shows up at their school but I
mean when I tell you that I could not
have imagined that even going back in
time in my brain if someone would have
showed up at school with a wet no way no
way it was not a concern and um and now
the fact that that is I mean it's become
a heightening fear it feels like because
this kind of stuff keeps popping up
wherever and I'm you know and people
could say it's for you know what what
causes it in this you know this
obviously there's certain factors
there's mental health there's weapons
you know those are those are two
elements of it for sure you know there's
there's probably a mix with a lack of
connection at the same time where people
aren't as connected to other people so
the value of a life doesn't it's not it
doesn't you know your life doesn't hang
you know other people's lives usually
hang inside of you like ornaments on a
tree you know they hold a certain amount
of weight and they you know they're
different they look different some of
them are snowflakes and some of them are
you know beautiful orbs and some of them
are you know crazy unique pieces of art
but they're all like ornaments
you know other people's lives you
interact with their they become
ornaments kind of that hang inside of
you and and you you you you learn to
value those ornaments and know what they
look like and are shaped like and what
colors they illuminate by by by
interacting with those people that's how
you know that's how you know how much
you care about someone that's how you
know how much love you have for someone
by interaction and I wonder if as we you
know is some of this the repercussions
of us not interacting as much as humans
is it video games and video games huge
thing people could say whatever video
games don't I man there wasn't a game
when I was I mean there was games there
were certainly games where you could you
know there were shooting games we were
shooting other people in war you know
there were bombing games I remember
airplane there was you know super
Mario's we could throw fireball you
could throw a fireball at somebody at
another Italian or another dinosaur but
they didn't it wasn't as you know they
now these games we were walking through
buildings with guns and if that you know
if that's so much easier
manok if you spend so much your life in
front of a screen and that's the only
place you get acceptance and you're
already damaged what does that all look
like how does that play out how does
that unfold it's just man it's just
harrowing it's harrowing the thing and I
didn't mean to get on too but otherwise
I shut down the schools have people
learn online or learn at home you know
we can't do home school because there's
nobody at home to teach kids anymore you
know to both parents have to work oh I
kind of wish we could date we could just
freeze everyone in America for a you
know for 48 hours or 72 hours or a week
just give everybody's brain a vacation
not like a vacation like on pills or
something but just a little bit of pee
you know I wish they could just put a
drop of gas all over the world that just
you know whenever you inhale it you know
you know what other people's lives are
like and so suddenly you have everywhere
you get all these other perspectives of
what people's lives are really like and
immediately you would know how to act
and behave because you have that
perspective like an empathy gas or
something that just immediately when you
when it gets in your lungs you just you
are overcome with empathy for others and
with perspective because this
competitiveness is so much competition
out there there's so much competition
you know it's like with social media and
everything it's like there's a it's like
there's an electronic score to feel good
you know it's like you have to get likes
and you have to get or you know these
things and this all could because I'm
living in LA you know I could be [ __ ]
you know just drowning in a swamp of
[ __ ] out here and I understand that
you know I live in the nation's capital
of greed out here and singularity and me
me me me but it's you know you wonder if
if because we rely so much on you know
these electronic this electronic
scorekeeping for our values or for what
makes us feel valued that you know if
you are somebody who's you know spends
most of their time playing video games
and you and that if the world just
doesn't turn in to one for you at a
certain point you know and then it's
just there's no you can't separate
what's you know real and what isn't
because you've had so much of what isn't
real you know like a first-person
shooter video game or something you've
had you've had so little of what is real
like human connection I don't know scary
scary time so what do we do what do we
do we get somebody we get each other
hold somebody's hand you know I'm saying
put your finger in somebody's ass put
your finger in your own ass and put you
know what I'm saying right somebody
else's name on your finger and put it in
your ass you know Janet or barb you know
you do something to to feel connected
touch somebody on the neck touch
somebody in that Lyons lick put your
hand right there let them know you care
you know take the afternoon off and take
your kid to the park
you know don't put them in double
stripes bra throw a [ __ ] I'll throw a
[ __ ] baseball at that kid but uh but
that's what's going on I'm rambling I
know I'm rambling some time I'm ramble
you know I'm a Rambler I'll tell you
what else gray block pizza get that
hitter I'm gonna read something at our
menu right now they got that neavy
Bianco red onion some onions you know
they're whatever they show up you don't
know what color they are you know
they're gender neutral or whatever red
onion fresh sliced tomato some places
you go get the pizza it's the full
tomatoes sitting on there you're like
what the [ __ ] is this you know you bite
into it and suddenly there's a gardener
across the room staring at you like
you're just molested is you know like
you just molested his favorite fruit or
vegetable Mazzarella fancy cheese
ricotta and they got garlic basil on a
garlic pesto sauce and that's great
block pizza get that era and you can uh
you can check that out at 1811 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles and they got
another place opening up its called
bronx-born pizza and that's up there in
Bend Oregon so if you get up there and
Bend and you out there in evergreen
country or or or I don't even know where
Bend is but if you're out there and you
bend in around once you bend on over to
our bronx-born and tell them Theo von
sent you and tell them you want that hit
off
ah dude look I got into the worst [ __ ] I
[ __ ] I left so listen to this so good
on a la jolla right and Allah I put my
car at the train station because I take
that train down for relaxation this
traffic man the traffic it feels I start
feeling disconnected and I you know I
take the train down and I lost my keys
in la jolla lost my car keys so I get
back up can't get into my car so I go to
the dealership they tell me I got to
order a key takes three days to get the
key so now I can't get my car to the
parking garage I had to order the key
the keys coming you know [ __ ] so now I
won't even get the key until Monday and
so my car at that point a little been in
there for ten days ten days in a parking
garage and no Carbon Avenue BRR an uber
is why I'm an uber you get out you know
some people want to talk to you some
people don't some people tell you their
life story some people trying to score
dust some people want you to you know
you want you to listen to a album you
know some people want to smell your
breath
they got wild people out there and I sit
in the front a lot of times I don't sit
in the back like one of these straight
mooks man I sit up front you know I'm up
and around with these cats I'll sit up
there we could smell each other's breath
you know I'm saying well we could rep
lunch on each other and that's how I do
it I mean we had a great conversation I
felt like on Mondays episode about the
about the about the states war and what
that would be what that would look like
man I can't tell if I'm correct here's
what I can't tell right now in my mind I
can't tell if I'm crazy for thinking
that America will continue to become
more separate or if it's just all a fad
that's out there in the media and I am
obviously affected by it and have bought
into it that's what I can't tell I just
can't tell you know I know people are
really divided on you know what's going
on and you know what their America looks
like in their idea
of America it's just it's it's crazy so
I can't you know sometimes i can't
decide if i got if you know in a hundred
years if i were to you know wake back up
out of the great eternity you know if I
were to straight up you know spelunk
down from heaven cuz you know daddy's
going to H town I'm sayin I ain't playin
around out here I'm tryin to end up in
hell I think trying to end up all hell
Euler I'm tryin to go up top that
penthouse that penthouse from my
Pittsburghers and it's uh you know it's
it just makes me wonder if you know what
it if it's if that's a real thing if I
came back in a hundred years if this if
if all the states would be divided it
would be like a little group here a
little group there you know and or if it
would just be just moving along we'd all
just be you know living off of Amazon
and stuck in our own little universes in
our homes
you know what that future is gonna look
like what's going on I just I don't know
I'm in a whirlwind I'm in a whirlwind
sometimes we are sometimes we are that's
where you got to batten down your
hatches how do you do that find
something that's real touch somebody up
on there lions litt [ __ ] somebody you
know [ __ ] somebody you love or love
somebody you [ __ ] you know have a
dessert with somebody split a brownie
split a lemon bar split a lemon bar with
somebody I'm saying by somebody's coffee
when you're at the counter you know you
see a mother struggling up there at the
thing hit her would have extra box of
[ __ ] loops for her kids hitter would
extra boxer loops you know sneak $20
into her cart when she ain't looking you
know you got to connect with somebody
you know it's stopping at the library
you know walk back in in a periodical
show somebody your [ __ ] nuts bro make
somebody feel something you know I'd
love to see somebody you know just just
walk into an Arby's in and just you know
give out free little pieces of chocolate
to everybody at Arby's just chalking up
Arby's
because we just need we need infections
of that valve that vibrant heartbeat you
know I wish I had a [ __ ] I wish I had
a bunch of a million little hearts I'd
put him in my hand and just starts
throwing him in [ __ ] BAM you
got loved-up bam bam bam bam bam hey
orders for short us
daddy's loving everybody give me a
little heart cannon just fire hearts off
into the distance you know a couple of
lesbians running on the beach BAM
one of them gets hit by that by that uh
by that beatmaker caught right in the
chin hurt her friend Sondra or whatever
her friend's name is helps rub what
happened to you you know Linda a lot of
lesbians are named Linda when I'm help
for what happened to you Linda and she
just all she knows is that Linda had
been hit by love and we got to get some
love loose in this world what do we do
what do we do what do we do what do we
do because it could end up you know if
she gets fish if she gets lit down here
people are ready at people I feel our
people caged up our people ready enough
to go to war the war the states what
would it look like you know where I
figured it out at last episode I broke
it down you know I felt like you'd have
Georgia
you'd have Texas you'd have that
Midwestern clan really led by Ohio and
they would probably you know settle up
in Chicago that would be their center
hub you'd have that Pacific Northwest
would all kind of merge over there in a
Utah or Idaho up in the high hills over
there over there if there's something
over there all the Montana the Dakotas
all of them come down and end up over
there you know you'd have that Northeast
has Syracuse and I met people from
Philly would merge better with people
from upstate New York then they would
with people from the rest of
Pennsylvania or with New York City I
think it's just more like this just
seems to me like more like like types of
people you'd have them merge up and so
then that's what your universe that's
what your America would look like that's
exactly what your America would look
like and get up Hawaii sitting out there
just pineapples titties probably titties
long dick everything out there
everything you
vagina everything pork everything pork
salad everything out there snacks
pineapple upside-down cake pineapple
treats frozen pineapples everything
orange slices boats everything joy
people doing it all out there in Hawaii
that's where they would be doing it Dog
the Bounty Hunter would be the president
out there you know long people doing all
types of naughty stuff and that would be
probably the one of the that would be
really a wild place but I knew you guys
had some thoughts on it too I'm gonna
crack into a couple of your thoughts I'm
just gonna hit a little bit of this
hotline in just a second you know about
that state's war we had a lot of people
called in about it I'll be in Tacoma
March 15th and 16th at the comedy club
March 17th I'll be at Spokane Spokane
I'm sorry April 6th and 7th I'll be in
Tampa Florida Rock Brothers brewing
Tampa those tickets are now on sale at
theof uncom slash torti oh you are April
20th and 21st I'll be in Hasbrouck
Heights New Jersey at bananas banana a
Spanish for banana also you can go to
the reddit.com I got my own read it out
there ready calm slash are slash Theo
von that conversation is gonna start
poppin we're gonna do some AMA s on
there soon so just wanted to let you
guys know I want to thank you guys so
much for calling in and hitting this
hotline I'm already excited about next
week's episode this has been a crazy
week you know I've been shooting that
pilot still today we had a today we had
basically we took someone who we called
him the podcast and we had him show up
today and we tried to you know help
bring some solution into their life in
real time and man we had a we it did we
had so much fun we had Ron Funches on
today if you haven't spent time around
Ron Funches he is I've never seen
anything like him he's one of a kind you
know he's a national treasure
and we got the pilot done you know and
it's long days on there see and you
can't think about
anything else it's hard to focus on
other things but tomorrow I'm gonna look
at some studio space you know I want to
get some guests in you know I got my got
booty I want to get booty in out of
Baton Rouge you know my one of my
favorite rappers of all time Bootsy and
Nellie you know also I want to get
Gerard Butler out there and tell him how
I feel you know and how I felt when I
see him and how I feel about when I you
know see that man you know I have some
ideal guests you know a couple of my
favorite authors I want to get people in
and be able to have them in studio you
know having them haven't met your house
is weird cuz you have somebody over you
got to do everything you know you got to
make sure they ain't you know popcorn
crumbs on the carpet you got a you know
Minoo you know catch those [ __ ] you
know they got turd freckles on the
toilet bowl you got to shine them down
you got to do all this extra stuff you
got a light of a candle you know you
can't fart all evening you got to make
sure you do stuff to make it exemplary
for somebody because nothing shady and
going over somebody's house that that's
you ever go to somebody's house that
stinks you're been to somebody's house
that stinks and they don't know it you
walk in and it's like and they're like I
live alone and you're like no you don't
you live with the ghosts of shits must
past because it smell like a bunch of
doodoo spirits up in here that's what it
smell like you get into somebody's house
and it's just I mean it you know you
don't even have to you don't have to
look around for it you don't have to
wander you don't have to be a you know
smell Gellin you don't have to
circumnavigate that house to know that
that best bounce some people houses
smell like that has been hot and do
doing stuff in their house like they got
a crock-pot under under one of the beds
or something with a couple of warm you
know a couple warm body turds grilling
out you know or some modern a you know
somebody hit a couple of
you know uncooked fish sticks somewhere
in their boudoir
you know we're something some people you
go to their house and always if it hears
that they unnoticed if your house stinks
is hot that's why I want to know what is
up hey if your house stink cut on the
air conditioner because you know what's
worse than just stink pot stink cool you
stink off that's gonna help people for
they're coming over you got a bunch of
stinky ass blankets and [ __ ] wash your
house out if your house is dirty wash
your [ __ ] house open the doors it's
spring cleaning man and we're gonna talk
about that in two weeks
spring cleaning Monday I'm already you
know we got a lot of stuff that's been
coming in about marriage and
relationship we're gonna get into some
of that come Monday but after that we're
gonna talk about spring cleaning because
if you how stink freshen that thing up
you know I'm saying I don't care if you
got a tie a couple slices of lemon
around your sister's neck and have her
sleep over a little bit get you house
scented well because it's you can be
living in stench you can't be living as
stench let's hit some of these uh some
of you guys is message from the states
war you know you guys had a lot of
thoughts and look I love this topic
because man you tell me America can't
Civil War we did it what 150 years ago
how long ago
two hundred years I don't even know when
we did it that's how I look I'll tell
you right now let me look it up I'll
look it up on the computer
Civil War dates 1861 to 1865 that's a
hundred and fifty years ago so that's
only three people ago three people ago
we were civil warring so you think it's
that far faster we could do it again the
American Civil War was a war that was
fought in the United States from
1861-1865 war broke out over slavery war
broke out in 1861 and this from
Wikipedia people you know have all say
all different reasons why the war broke
out etc but I'm telling you that's what
it says right here I'm reading that off
of here
so if you're telling me that at a
certain point war might not break out
because maybe 1% of the population has
all the money or some people have all
the money could that happen I don't know
I don't know if that could happen
because poor people don't like to poor
people do not work together a lot of
times you know poor people long as they
have poor people divided you know I
don't see that happening but what's
going to be that I or what's gonna be
that thing man it's an it it's exciting
too it's exciting to wake up and be like
[ __ ] I have today I have to think I have
to stand for something today I have a
reason I have a little bit of purpose I
believe in this and I believe in that or
I don't even know what I believe in
that's what I'm trying to live at
sometimes I don't know but I'm ready to
learn baby I'm ready to take a nail I'm
ready to take a eat and a and are in and
I'm ready to learn up let's hit a call
right here this came in boom boom for
your diet do live free to die that's
what New Hampshire's coming with do we
all we all rock together with that [ __ ]
believe it live free or die you heard
him and that's this your boy Rico coming
out and out of New Hampshire calling in
about that states war
tell me more reek is Rico and let me
just say this we're gonna call in saying
that their state isn't gonna win the war
what kind of what kind of mentality is
that to go into war with that [ __ ]
brutal well they got some kind a state's
out there you know what is it somewhere
is the land of lovers where is that
place well look you try to hug a
[ __ ] with a machete gang gang
you're gonna lose that hug more and for
anyone to call up and say that state
isn't gonna take I don't even know what
that's about
well they had the guy from Maine that
called it I'm you know onward sorry
interrupting you
onward Rico have no you
no no passion no love your infestation
bro it's small enough where we all kind
of know each other we got those crazy
[ __ ] down Seabrook down on the
coast
what do first of all small enough we all
know each other do the same a
quinceanera man this is a war you can't
be you know I'm saying you can't be like
Oh Randy just got here
that [ __ ] can't happen on the
battlefield this ain't a pickup game you
know you can't be down there and be like
Oh who's who we dressing out for this
man come on man Seabrook you said we got
it oh we got those Mad Hatter's down
would you say here let me listen to this
one more time let's hear this all kind
of know each other we got those crazy
[ __ ] down he look down with
Seabrook penitentiary
Dennis see what is Seabrook it sound
like a rich people haha homestead area
on the water what you got rich people in
a Seabrooke what they do and driving
sobs man you can take what are they
gonna do throw fancy jewelry of people
I'm saying you can't you can't [ __ ]
you can't beat you can't beat somebody
to death with it with a wristlet you
know widow with a 14-karat gold
candelabra this ain't clue this ain't
clue the board game you got to come with
something real let's hear more down on
the coast we got like 13 miles of
shoreline we got those Hampton Beach
critters we got the mountains we get
what mountains dude the mountains of New
Hampshire what do y'all got man I look
up this [ __ ] cat [ __ ] claim right now
mountains of New Hampshire what do y'all
have just say right here Mount
Washington 6,200 feet [ __ ] listen Rico
uncle Rico could throw a football over
that thing that ain't nothing you got
Loon Mountain 3,000 feet do it all back
flip off of that [ __ ] what else y'all
got nothing Wildcat Mountain I'm looking
at the pitch of the first picture of it
right here on
on Google Images you got too thick
frosty whites hanging out by a sign say
toilets this way man this ain't no [ __ ]
y'all ain't got an army bruh this dude
got man tits right there he got tits
hanging off his elbows
he got them elbow titties boy come on
man I'm gonna let you go a little more
let's hear more Rico an alien border
okay now you got the Canadian border
that's huge
we got those wild boys out in Keene
State College
we got Plymouth State College Dartmouth
we have them drawing up schematics new
New Hampshire is taking this [ __ ] it's
not I'm in the artists it's not even
close not even close to what you got
people drawn up schematics
what is that ski Maddox dude this thing
this ain't the Iditarod brother
this ain't cross-country ski and man
this is war you got people out of cane
state do you have better colleges if
they say it's cane come on dude Keene
State come on there's not a lot of us
but we're here we're here that's your
motto
dude that sound like a shitty motel
chain we're here oh we're we're gonna
take over Maine
quick oh yeah yeah oh I believe that
dude Maine ain't nothing bruh Maine up
there eating poisonous berries dude you
know it's a bunch of stoners acting like
they know what the wilderness is about
48 hours outside rather be in that
freezing cold rain accidentally eat a
poisonous berry Gang Gang done call it a
wild let's hear more
there's townships in Maine that are not
incorporated into the United States
that's how just makin it is so we're
gonna move in there take a little
banquet and we're just kind of going to
kind of lay low that quick take over
maintain the Keene and lay low lay low
right you're gonna be tired
lay low Y all hopped up on syrup New
Hampshire man look I respect it but I
don't see any chance bro no Hampshire
you got no Hampshire dude the
thing y'all will have is a flag that
have a HAMP on it baby gang gang um
we're let's take another call here
reppin a reppin Cali here this about
that state civil war let's hear more
with the vo that is mando calling from
California Oh mando and that's sound
like a Spanish name mando and um
mando I don't know what it means mando
mando mando it sound like it means uh
you know mando mando mando sound like a
strong man or he used to be strong and
now he's you know letting himself go a
little bit but the ladies I'll remember
him is strong you know who that's mando
here we go thank you for calling mando
um I heard your input on kind of a funny
saying you think everybody will leave
but I don't know I think we'll hold it
down you know California has those gangs
too man you gotta take the infinite
account and all those people that are
from here and those immigrants and stuff
that we got they'll be the first on the
front of the line that will put you know
I don't take out yet they could do some
families you know get a crackhead or a
wino fighting for you now I'll say this
now look I'll come a crackhead will be
the best lookout cuz crackheads can go
for about 86 hours before they die I
mean they're basically like it's like
getting a you know one of those
remote-controlled cars and just running
the battery straight about eighty six
hours crackhead up all night look out
look out you know they'll take a part of
tank they'll do whatever crackhead to be
all up all night you know you wake up in
the morning crackhead caught three
rabbits and sold all your guns and
everything you know that's the only
thing you don't know what kind of trades
they're gonna make in the middle of the
night if you have crackheads working
with you and you got the gangs that's
true you got the gangs but but gangs are
always hear hear what word do you hear
with gangs rival rival gangs our gangs
gonna work together with anybody mm-hmm
gangs when we fighting each other for
small territory now gang gangs are used
to claiming territory so you're gonna
have that right there out of the gate
you know these gangs are gonna be used
to reppin territory but I think you can
have so much interaction between those
gangs
they're not going to be able to
coagulate and form one cohesive unit
before that you said what you said oh
that I thought a lot of people would
leave well I think that people in
militaries are going to leave and go
back to their respective home states
where their home family lives I don't
think just because you're stationed at
Fort Polk or Fort Benning or Fort Bragg
that you're suddenly gonna stay in
Louisiana or George or or Kansas I don't
think just because you know you're
stationed over at davis-monthan Air
Force Base and if you don't have any
children or your family there that
you're not gonna go and fight for your
home territory you know that's that
those are the people that I think will
leave illegal immigrants what are they
going to do now that's a tough call I
don't know [ __ ] I'm not supposed to be
here and now they want me to fight for
this place deuces baby deuces
you know I was at a um what is that
chicken place called I was at a Church's
Chicken and you think it's kind of a
religious thing but it's not it just
says churches in the name you go in
there and it's damn I mean it's the
devil you know it's the devil running a
deep fryer and I was at this Church's
Chicken his [ __ ] broke out in there one
time and I kind of you know they had a
couple of people fighting in there and
I'll be honest it was a couple of
brothers and sisters man and you know
they liked to fight at fast food places
a lot you've seen the videos online I'm
not gonna pretend this isn't a this
isn't a thing that happens and so then
the people at the you know they weren't
arguing with the people and fighting
with the people who worked at the at the
churches at that chicken house and the
people at churches the dudes like dude
get back here on our side [ __ ] I
don't want to work for churches I don't
have I ain't having a you know a strong
brother [ __ ] deep-fry my arms just so
I can defend a couple of nine pieces and
y'all [ __ ] I'm out of here
that's when I left I ran up the backdoor
that churches you know so I'm saying
I've been I've run through the kitchen
of a fast-food establishment so when you
looking at me know that about me
people tsunami-like wonder what that
dude is done wonder who he is what's up
with him well I'll tell you straight up
during regular business hours
I've ran through the the full the the
full breadth and in in space of a
fast-food establishment and ran out the
back door okay
I've gotten that that hit a hot dirty
garbage right when you hit open that
back door him you feel that you know
that waft catch a neck I've gotten that
but what I'm saying is that's the same
thing about illegal immigrants when the
[ __ ] hits the fan and they don't work
for the fan by they ain't staying a
[ __ ] they stand to thunk to to
weather the shitstorm dog when [ __ ] hits
the fan and I don't work for the fan
sayonara I think staying here illegal
immigrants will be gone hey stay here in
defend California [ __ ] I'm from
Venezuela dude I'm from Toronto [ __ ]
I'm out so that's what's gonna happen
there let's hear more thank you for
calling mondo and then you got all them
gang members with them guns and whatnot
then you just got all them savage
farmers we have so I don't know I think
I think California would take it all you
know well now you guys you have a huge
population and somebody called about
that the other day if somebody has a
large population and they have a lot of
guns you know and even if only one out
of ten people is armed if you have a
hundred million people then that's which
no state has but if you have thirty
million people
then you're gonna have three million
guns in your state that's a lot less
you're more do that the min can be like
nobody and everybody who comes out here
they're out here pursuing something so
they're fighters too you know okay I
might stay back up California in you
know you're not from here
building's not from here so you guys
will put up a fight for us no so I think
California has the upper hand with
everybody that is here nope look ma I
mean look you have and it's obvious you
have a lot of state pride and I respect
that a hundred percent and I'll respect
your opinion
I respect your opinion but I do deny
anybody's staying out here you think I'm
staying out here next to some of these
Lilly [ __ ] out here in Los
Angeles all these people over here all
these accountants and [ __ ] artists
all these agents and Muppets and PRS
[ __ ] man they staying in my house
then sipping off a daddy's candle soup
you know that split pea is for me then
getting this something I'm not gonna die
mechana stand shoulder to shoulder yeah
I think the place is with a sense of
community that is very strong may have a
stronghold so now that's a great point
that you could you kind of are bringing
that up that I think you will see a
strong sense of community in you know
NorCal those people have a stronger
sense of community Los Angeles I think
you'll have the rich people will get off
all onto their boats anyone with a boat
is gonna have a good chance of survival
because they're gonna be able to
separate themselves immediately from
99.9% of the friction so anywhere
anybody the boat they're slipping out
you know they slipping out on that soft
h2o carpet that water the Pacific Ocean
Atlantic Ocean Gulf of Mexico [ __ ]
probably people out there and Lake Huron
you know people out there stunting in
the middle tying a couple boats up you
know bringing a bottle of uh you know a
couple cases of Redd's Apple ale and
cracking off out there I mean I mean I
I'll just say this I would not stand
here and fight for California now in the
beginning I might have to to defend my
my territory I would you know I would
band together with some of the people
here in in the building that I live in I
would make sure that my love people that
I love that are close by if I could that
they are taking care of but well dude
I'll tell you I'm headed straight
probably over there Louisiana Texas
that's why I would probably go I'll
probably try to stop in at Colorado on
the way if I could
I appreciate the call Monday let's hear
more CEO Alex from Colorado
speak of the devil right here speak of
that of that Red Rock holder right here
that devil Colorado let's hear more
talking about the United States of
jangheung I'm originally from Georgia I
appreciate you telling a saying that we
might come out in the semi-finals
that's probably true but Colorado we got
the air force out here you know we got
those sky hitters gang
y'all got them okay you got the air
force out there and maybe those guys a
lot of the guys are from there now if
they have family there they might stay
and just protect their immediate family
so at that point you're in with the
state but otherwise you might just have
a graveyard of planes and a lot of dudes
that you know only know how to play a
Final Fantasy and you know that ain't a
xbox controller in the cockpit more we
also got you know something called the
Rockies and the Colorado River okay so
they got water and most these [ __ ]
yuppie states around here sucking up our
water there wouldn't be nothing without
our Colorado liquid gold that's a huge
point and I do believe that California
gets a lot of their water from Colorado
oh I'd popped up for it and finished it
it sells water to 95% of the South Coast
region Lake Mead former Hoover Dam is a
primary reservoir in the Colorado River
Basin where do we get our water from in
California Colorado River aqueduct Wow
so right there wow that's huge let's
hear more all right now Colorado's
definitely making the semi-finals now
we've got another problem up there
called Alaska
the North Pole and I you know that Santa
is gonna be their general and nobody
gonna shoot Santa so that's gonna be you
got that when you got there people out
there Kris Kringle 'n ohm word where the
hell we even gonna find these people
even fight them they're out in the
middle of nowhere man
so I think they might make it to the
semi Texas for sure makin is this dummy
they got border agents down there a
couple of infantry guys down there so
you know Colorado Alaska Texas we're all
going to make it out okay yeah that's
what I think all right
stake the crash I'll stay fresh man
thank you and you stay pressed my hand
I'll last can't even think about that in
Alaska they can have that I mean Alaska
day but who's gonna go all the way up
there and fight Alaska now I'm saying it
no offense Alaska cuz I honestly get a
lot of calls in from Alaska but Alaska
lot of men out there y'all relax and
y'all gonna come over down here and what
fight somebody I don't know I don't
think so
so you guys would become you know
probably a sovereign nation you know you
guys would just probably come down every
now and then and trade first some of the
other um you know some of the other new
states that are formed but I appreciate
that that water that water thing is huge
if Colorado stops that water that's a
wrap that's a wrap for California all
them vegetables all them fruits you know
I don't think they have enough other
saline solutions that can purify and
who's gonna operate them whoo that's
huge
let's hear more here we go yo Theo this
is David from South Texas I just wanted
to throw my vote in to the great states
war thanks for calling David it's here
more you know I am from Texas I would
say we probably had the best shot out of
all the states to succeed in the state
war
yep I agreed with that onward because
you got to think about most of the state
here packing heat you know carrying guns
and that's just we're not even in war
with anybody right now we're still we're
already carrying guns as it is like
right now on me I have huge 12-inch
combat knives here in my car damn I
thought he's gonna say [ __ ]
I like dang man you got that wild cop
just because it's a place where I work
at kind of ghetto and you never know
it's gonna go down with these homeless
people walking around but I know for a
fact that you know most girls women
carry a piece on them nowadays in their
purse erection right there immediately I
was erect I went from zero to full [ __ ]
right there in this [ __ ] ain't on half a
tank this thing running full with a
woman with a piece man and no disrespect
to women they don't carry guns and some
on me a woman with a bow and arrow
doesn't do it that much for him you see
a woman pull out of dang you know that
Jam up that bangbang daddy getting
strong in the dome son you feel like my
dick been doing curls cuz that thing's
starting to lump up and lump out more or
you know in the car yeah everybody here
is pretty stocked up on guns and ammo
and stuff so we wouldn't need a lot of
guns shift into the state I think we
would have enough to like spare for
everybody
we'd be set on ammo as well we got
people who make their own ammo man first
of all somebody making their own ammo
right using somebody's bootleg ass ammo
where does shit's gonna go straight is
this some Australian ammo to stick gonna
come back around and you know kill my
cousin kill little Larry come on man
more you know reloading old bullets and
stuff like that
we got the livestock the cattle oil wood
resources anything we'd probably be set
you know just as you saw with hurricane
Harvey all these Texans coming together
and you know providing for each other
and fighting for each other and rescuing
each other out of boats and stuff and
these little canals Barney houston we
have a waterway access as well so that's
true down there through Galveston you
guys do have access and I think that's
only another Gulf of Mexico though man
you know you know you made me think
there how greedy are people gonna get
though you know when somebody have all
that live sucking all of that how are
you know that's gonna be huge if people
are willing to band together because I
my first thought is every it's they
don't say every man for themselves for
no reason you know would it just be
would we be able as humans to even band
together as States that's another
question but man I appreciate that call
and I you know a lot of good points a
lot of good food for thought
a lot of good fodder a lot of good stuff
we had another call last week and I want
to see if I can I mean I can't play that
for you cuz I don't have it but we had a
lady that called in and she was talking
about prostituting you know and I hate
to put it like that just straight up
like that but but that's what it was
about you know we had a lady that uh
that called in was just talking about
prostitute and saying her family was
having tough times and she wasn't doing
really well and she had had offers she
was a young lady she had had offers from
men high dollar amounts for someone had
asked her for some sex and it makes you
and and it was tough to hear that but
also we you know we're these are
desperate times out here for a lot of
people you know there's a there's a lot
of there's a few really well-off people
and there's a lot of people who are not
and that
thing is man there's a level agreed out
there because in order for some people
to be really rich other people have to
be poor it's got to stay like that and
I'm not saying that I'm gonna that I'm
against capitalism that I'm against us
you know you work hard and you get what
is yours and you go forth you know
because you got to have that
competitiveness you have to have it I
think if you just gave everybody the
same amount of stuff it just it's not
going to work you know because
somebody's then is just gonna want more
than their neighbor or somebody you give
everybody something and everybody has a
chore but the next day the first one
person doesn't show up for their chores
then everybody hates that person and
doesn't think they should have what they
have and boom that's how it starts and
then fast forward a hundred years and
you have capitalism you know when you
have every man for themselves and it's
just you know it's like you know it's
not surprising that the you know these
are the kind of questions and things
that people are calling in about okay
this was the call that came in I was one
of let you guys get one more hit of it
real quick before we get into the
suggestions that came in from other
callers so onward hey CEO I kind of
needed your input opinion on the fact
that I been basically propositioned by
wealthy men to entrance and sort of like
relationship even before you like turned
18 it wasn't going on and I recently
moved to LA and the concentration of
this pressing is at an all-time high and
we'll stop it right there I mean that's
just the gist of it you know she goes
into saying that her family's having
trouble and stuff like that but let's
hear some suggestions that you guys had
for this young lady and I hope that
she's listening I haven't heard these
yet but I am I'm excited to hear him
here we go hey yo this is Alexios down
here in Clearwater Florida
Alexios and that is um I must say that
that's Greek or Spanish maybe Alexius
Honduran something you sound like a
chant like you like you could win a
contest I don't know what kind of
contest though you know maybe some
flamenco but thank you for calling
Alexis
man I feel like my tongue just came even
after I said that they Aleksey us let's
hear more thank you for calling I'm
calling in regards to that girl that
thinking of getting into prostitution
like my thoughts are like if she doing
it for herself then I don't really see a
problem with it you know but it's her
body she could do whatever she wants
with it
but if she doing it for her family I
think he's gonna start developing
animosity at some point for her family
you know and resent me and also what's
the number that he'll need to make in
order to make impact with her family you
know that's a great point
yeah you do that's true but cuz a lot of
times we do things and we you know if I
say I did that for somebody there will
your family ever be able to thank you or
make you feel welcome enough so that you
you know you feel like you don't have to
you know like you feel like that's not
something you would do again you know
will your family ever be able to you
know make thank you enough or make you
feel repaid enough where you wouldn't
hold it against them I don't know if
that's possible you know I just don't
know if that's possible let's hear more
but you know how much money will she
have to me I don't know I think that's a
good look very slow you know if she's
doing it first so that's fine but it's
gonna be doing it for a family you know
it's good to take care of family but at
some point you have to take care of
yourself and also if their family finds
out what she's getting the money from
they're also gonna be judging her so
it's like a lose-lose situation and it's
also gonna affect her future life and it
will impact a personality I just think
that the best thing she could do for her
family is be there for them emotionally
and love them as long as we know that
she loves them as a that's about as much
to do for them it's a good call like cos
there's some great points you know how
much would be enough and when you start
into that how you know when does it end
it's just a dangerous world
Alexios thank you for the call let's
hear another one here we go hey Theo
it's Robyn from Atlanta
hey Robyn from Atlanta one of the
semi-finalists states in the war of the
states more I called in to talk to the
18 year old who's thinking about selling
her cooter this really upset me calling
to listen to your show and laugh and
about things with discipline got me it
yeah and I'm sorry about that I know
look I don't know someone we gonna you
know I don't know if I'm sorry about it
sometimes we can Oh tough topics man you
know and on stage you come see this
hitter I'll hit him well Sammy Sosa you
know I'm saying I'll show up with a bat
in my hands and a needle in my ass bruh
I'll be Sammy Sosa McGwire you know I'll
be Sammy Sosa McGwire Jeter
[ __ ] whoever else out there but you
know you come see me on this podcast
somehow things get real in here look
more let's hear more Thank You Robyn
Bonnie and I want to talk directly to
her by first thing who told you that
your family's dead is your
responsibility that's [ __ ] I mean
that you can't take care of yourself yet
so what makes you think you can take
care of yourself and now everybody
dreams of making a big life for their
family and give them in the house and
showering them with love but you can't
do that yet and that's a great point you
know especially at your age young lady
I'm gonna support Robins eye suggestion
there that yeah you have this dream that
you want to help your family so much
but you don't see all the ramifications
of some of your choices yet you can't
see them at your age more that's miles
and miles away and you don't really go
up from being a hooker yes there's no
into the corporate chain there I think
what bothers me the most is that this
six and I and I don't disagree with that
overall but there's a lot of hookers out
here in Los Angeles who are probably
CEOs right now you know and I'm not
saying Chelsea Handler but I maybe
wouldn't be surprised you know I think
there's a lot of you know people that
have you know hypothetically been a
hooker to make their way to the top more
the sex trade business is a real
business I mean someone finds you
selling high dollar [ __ ] and they're
gonna want in on it and they're not
going to ask you
Wow Vaness having this [ __ ] just got
rushed and all of a sudden didn't it
seem rushed and suddenly suddenly just
felt a bunch of Russian dudes enter the
room more I mean people disappear off
the face of this earth every day in this
business and it's scary
and I don't know who these men are that
are propositioning you and you make them
sound like complete strangers I mean if
that doesn't send us some
morning bells for you I don't know what
to say I think it does send up warning
bells because you've already said that
this is something that you're you know
is wrong maybe not morally wrong because
I certainly want everybody to to enjoy
the fruits of life don't hold that but
this is not the time and this is not the
thing to launch your career right yeah
and uh yeah and I don't think that she's
trying to launch a career but yeah but
this isn't the path thank you for that
call Robin here we have another call
here we go
and I know I'm just jumping called a
call here but you know I part of me does
want to comment too much on this
personally because I already did the
other day and you know I just want to
hear y'all suggestions here we go I'm
calling in regards to young lady calling
in about prostituting herself out a
little bit to some money to help the
family she didn't sound like she really
wanted to do that to me
and so my advice to her is don't do that
there's always another way to get past
something and I know I grew up with mom
and three sisters and it would [ __ ]
kill me inside that hearing one of them
doing something like that and there you
go and there's that message I don't know
if I the young lady has a brother or
sibling or whatever there you go that's
that message that that's that voice at
the end and you know sometimes that's
what it is about people calling in to
this to this podcast in this show
sometimes that that thing you hear that
the the call that comes in from a caller
that that might just be you know it
doesn't even matter who they are it
could be a that could just be the voice
of a brother or a father or a sister or
a mother or a an aunt and that's what
you need to hear you know that brother
right now that's any brother that's in
that that gentleman who called on you if
he gave his name Erica that's any that's
any gentleman that's any brother
probably just calling on behalf of their
sister you know or their if they you
know and giving that thought yeah it's a
that's a sticky one you know how do you
getting us to in a place inside yourself
were you able to do that I don't know
and I don't know how bad you know things
are
you young lady but you know being there
for your family 100% they're gonna
respect that I know that but uh you know
and I don't know if you've already made
some choices or whatever if you have you
know you can always change things
you know one of the worst things I've
ever heard is that a leopard never
changes its spots I mean I don't believe
that I believe that with effort and
willingness leopard can can look like
anything it wants to just take a little
bit of it just take a little bit of time
I appreciate you guys being here today
with me you know we're gonna we're gonna
wrap it up
you know I will already told you the
dates where I'll be at I want to thank
everybody that hamstrings video will be
coming out in a few days you know a
Monday's episode will be talking about
relationships marriage and that sort of
thing and I'll give all that into you
guys on Monday
and sorry if this episode is a little
heavy man they're saying you know my son
anxiety does feel gone so no it's just
God have a place to talk and this is the
place that I have right now and some
time well you know this will be funny
and some of it'll be whatever it's a
conversation that's what we're having
here this is a conversation it's you
know you guys helped me think of things
sometimes that I don't want to think
about in ways that I can't think about
things you know together we make a you
know I feel like we make a pretty unique
shape I do believe that thank you guys
for being with me thank you
great block pizza thank you for
everybody support oh I did get this gift
you know I got a gift last week and I
just want to read the card came in the
mail it said happy Valentine's Day sugar
bear from your HAMP squad Kevin and
Nancy J and Hailey and Loretta and Wanda
and and this was a Valentine that they
sent me and I get things from time to
time they don't always thank people in
here but they sent me this Valentine and
I'm will crack this header right here
so everybody can see what daddy got
infected with through the mail here
and these packages are so strong whoo
that astronaut ice cream that's what I
got oh that cookies and cream vanilla
ice cream sandwich all my favorite
flavors and this is my favorite dessert
and if you never had astronaut ice cream
it's a great snack tab it's a great
dessert it's only 140 calories and
astronauts heat it to be thinking that
you can be digesting and throwing into
your gullet the same thing that a man on
the moon had come on what's that in your
mouth
mmm tastes like uh tastes like the
atmosphere that's what it tastes like
tastes like I'm the first person to do
something you know be inspired be
inspired thank you guys for my wonderful
gift thank you HAMP squad thank you
Kevin I love you guys you guys be good
I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
celebrate
celebrate ms
[Music]
while we all die
celebrate
they are